hello everyone and welcome to that
special day of the year it is the 9th of
November and it is of course the
birthday of the great former world
champion mik tal he got his Grandmaster
title in 1957 and already in 1959 in the
great candidates Tournament of 1959 uh
he won and he won the the the right to
challenge the reigning world champion M
binik for the title which he won in 1860
so uh we've seen a lot of TS games we've
shown pretty much all of TS great games
on this channel already but I still have
a few of them that I have saved for
special occasions like this one when
it's his birthday for example uh to show
you now in this game uh he's playing a
gentleman named katski he's playing in a
simultaneous exhibition and he sacrifice
his Queen so many times that I I've
literally lost count and I I challenge
you watch this video and try to figure
out how many times tal has offered his
Queen so let's check it out tal has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to E
E4 we have Pawn to E5 Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and Bishop to B5 going for
the real Lopez A6 morphe's defense
Bishop to A4 and now Knight to F6 we
have castles Bishop to E7 uh and Rook to
E1 we have Pawn to B5 and now Bishop to
B3 so very very standard stuff being
played here we have castles Pawn to C3
and now Pawn to D5 going for the
Marshall attack and this is how tal
replies e captures on D5 and now almost
everyone plays Knight captures on D5 and
then you have a trade on E5 and then you
choose what you will play but not Mr
katki here here he plays Pawn to E4 sort
of um pushing pushing the Marshall
attack even further uh and what can you
do here okay T plays D captures on C6
with have e captures on F3 and now Pawn
to D4 a very important move in any line
of of the Marshall uh Bishop to D6 and
now Bishop to G5 but what do you gain by
pinning the Knight as it's not really
pinned well Koski says all right Mr tal
show me he plays Bishop captures on H2
with check King captures and now Knight
to G4 a check that will win back the
material King to G1 and now Queen
captures on G5 we have Queen captures on
F3 and now Bishop to F5 there are a
couple games where H5 was played also
Knight to F6 is a non move but Bishop to
F5 here is a new move so already as of
move 15 we have a completely new game we
did in 1959 so okay Knight to D2 tal
tries to offer a knight for the bishop
on F5 as this Knight will have a hard
time of entering the game unless it is
allowed the D2 square and pawn to H5
it's best to decline this trade we have
Knight to E4 attacking the queen and
here katki trades Bishop for Knight we
have Bishop captures not Queen captures
but rather Rook captures and now King to
H7 unpinning from this um diagonal he
wants to play Pawn to F5 but now tal
just plays Bishop back to C2 even though
it's actually objectively okay to
capture on F7 uh but as it's a
simultaneous exhibition I imagined tal
wanted to uh play something that
requires uh less uh calculating so he
played Bishop to C2 now he's threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries here and
katki just unpins King to h8 we have
Rook 8 to E1 uh doubling up on the E
file and only Now Pawn to F5 we have
Rook to e Rook to E7 uh moting The Rook
to a pig and now Pawn to F4 grabbing
more space on the king side but also
opening up this diagonal once again for
tal uh Pawn to D5 tal shows that even
though uh this is a crazy game he still
needs to look really really far into the
future uh and plan this D6 push to allow
C captures on D6 and then to create a
past C Pawn which might at some point
Queen so okay Queen H4 going after Queen
to H2 check so Pawn to D6 th says all
right you go for it uh and now Queen to
H2 with check King to F1 and queen back
to H4 you don't really gain anything by
giving a check the king easily escapes
but by playing Queen to H4 uh now you
are threatening the White Queen cannot
move as the queen captures an F2 will be
checkm and also Knight H2 check will
Fork the queen and the white king So
King to E2 T starts running away with
the King and now Rook a to d8 just to
give you an example of what happens if C
cat on D6 if you could play this you
probably would be okay if if you could
play it but you can't play it the point
is now tal can play Queen to E4 threaten
Checkmate and once you play Queen
captures on F2 check King to D1 and
Knight to F6 you attack the queen and
defend against Checkmate here Queen to
G6 and now uh let's say you offer a
queen trade Queen to G3 now Rook
captures on G7 and after Queen captures
Rook captures uh this will be
objectively winning for uh for tal for
example if Rook 88 you offer a trade
then even at tricks like these are in
the position Rook captures on F6 and if
Rook captures on E1 with check perfectly
fine Rook captures and now C7 the pass C
Pawn wins the game if the Rook blocks
even Bishop to F5 now you offer a bishop
to promote the the pawn to a queen so
that's why C captures and D6 cannot be
played right away so Rook a to d8 first
uh and now we have Rook to H1 a
beautiful move by tal point is that tal
wants to play Queen to E4 and he wants
to go for checkm on H7 but if you play
it now then this check will be a problem
it's a similar line to what we've shown
but now after Knight to F6 uh Queen can
go to G6 but now you just play Rook
captures on D6 and it comes with check
which is a big problem you move the king
queen to G3 and it's not as nice and the
in as in the line that we've shown so
here T plays something that can only be
described as a tall move and that is
Rook to H1 he wants the Queen off of the
df2 square and he wants to be able to
play Queen to F4 so let's see what T had
in mind Queen captures on H1 was played
Queen to E4 now threatening Checkmate on
H7 Knight to F6 defending and now Queen
to G6 okay threatening Checkmate on G7
but now notice that the king is not on
the dile you do not have Queen captures
on D Rook captures on D6 with check so
Rook to G8 blocking this and now D
captures on C7 attacking The Rook here
Rook D to f8 and now C8 with Queen T
brings a queen a new Queen inter game
and immediately sacrifices it so Rook
captures on C8 and now look at this
queen captures on F6 that was the point
getting rid of The Rook from defending
F6 now you sacrifice the queen and you
cannot capture it due to Rook to H7
Checkmate let's not forget about our
good friend the bishop on the C2 Square
so instead after this um uh Queen
captures we have Pawn to F3 with check
so you have to capture G captures on F3
now Rook C back to E8 Now The Rook
cannot move now G captures on F6 is a
threat because the Rook is pinned to the
king but what a sty play he unpins it
Bishop to E4 now again if you capture
the queen this is Checkmate since uh the
bishop is in the way of the rook and the
king so Rook captures an E7 T recaptures
and now Queen to C1 here katki wants to
starts uh checking the white king from
from this side of the board Queen to E5
so at least once you capture here you're
not going to be able to to take
everything but also just threatening
Queen captures on H5 Checkmate so Queen
captures on B2 check King to F1 we have
Queen to C1 with check and King to G2
now Queen to H6 you have to defend the
H5 Pawn now comes Pawn to C7 see how
that D5 move uh really really matters
this game uh the pawn is now up all the
way to C7 we have Rook to f8 and now we
have Queen to F5 T again offers his
Queen and uh you can't really take it if
you you take it Dental gets another
queen into the game with check with the
bishop covering H7 there's really not
much you can do here King H7 Queen
captures an F5 check let's say G6 Queen
F7 and now you can simply trade down
into an end game where you will be up a
full Bishop even Bishop captures and G6
with check King H6 you can capture here
King captures Bishop captures and you
will be up a full Bishop so instead
after Queen to F5 G6 was played but it
doesn't really matter tal plays Queen uh
captures on f8 he gives up the queen
This Way Queen captures on f8 and now
Bishop to B7 preparing to bring another
queen into the game and he was in this
position on move 41 that uh katki
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so really wild game
especially for 1959 as we do not know
anything more on this U gentleman who
katki was uh obviously he played a very
strong chess and he knew Theory well he
went for the Marshall attack he went for
a very rare line of the Marshall that no
one ever plays today as it's not really
that spectacular uh but yeah he M work
for his meal and in a simultaneous
exhibition I don't know how many players
were in the simultaneous exhibition is
not a lot is known about this if you
have any other uh info about this Sim
will do use uh uh do put in the comment
section below and I will uh make at
least another video on this event where
I will explain what really really
happened there uh but yeah brilliant
game uh I challenge you to out how many
times T offered his Queen how many times
it was taken successfully uh what is
your what is your verdict uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed a
big a big happy birthday to mik tal uh
we are very happy to check out a game uh
whenever whenever we can and as we've
covered pretty much all of them we save
uh all the ones that we can for for for
for that next big birthday uh so yeah
once again hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank ghard hlan perforce La
Marie Florida iguana and T breeders K
Elsa K Elis rodella and Andre shred for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day